china estadounidense irrumpió por
partida doble en la competencia del
festival de cannes
[Música]
a sus 80 años Martín scorsese regresó a
la presentar fuera de la competencia su
última y muy esperada película Killers
of the Flower Moon reuniendo por primera
vez a dos de sus actores predilectos
Robert de Niro y Leonardo DiCaprio
[Música]
esta cinta es la adaptación
cinematográfica de una novela inspirada
en hechos reales la masacre de decenas
de miembros de la tribu ozark hace un
siglo en Estados Unidos
[Música]
los dorsal fueron el pueblo más rico del
mundo luego de que se descubriera
petróleo en sus tierras riqueza que
suscitó una serie de asesinatos
misteriosos para desposeerlos de sus
títulos de propiedad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es una leyenda del cine subió a la
alfombra roja de cannes 47 años después
de haber sido premiado en este certamen
por Taxi Driver por su parte May de
sember del también estadounidense
toddhains intentará rivalizar en la
competencia con esta historia
relacionada con el mundo del espectáculo
está protagonizada por dos
superestrellas del cine Nataly portman y
Julián Moore esperadas y muy aplaudidas
en la alfombra roja de cannes
[Aplausos]